tom nice great to see you uh
let me get this straight extreme pumpkin
carving is pumpkin carving
using uh basically machinery that could
kill somebody is that right that's
basically it and this is to get the job
done
quickly more efficiently is that right
right because i'm lazy okay you're lazy
well
no joke i did uh a pumpkin for my
daughter last night it took about two
and a half hours to carve it up
i was bruised and beaten at the end so
this is definitely the way to go is that
right yeah you can't let the pumpkins
win you got to get to them
can't let the pumpkins win that's a
great motto for halloween
those bastards have to die all right uh
why don't you start us off tell us
what's the first thing to do
well the first thing is to take the top
off the pumpkin so i use this thing a
reciprocation i see that you're wearing
safety equipment and i am not
i should probably put on these goggles
right here is that correct good idea
yeah and
and you're using a reciprocating song
yeah so i jab it in there like this
yeah pull the trigger
[Applause]
okay i don't even see what saw that is
over here i don't even know how to do
that
so it's this one here i don't even know
how to turn it on i'm such a thumb on
that one
oh no i'm so scared oh there we go right
like that okay
all right squeeze it like this okay and
then you just sift this in here yeah
and then just make all yeah
okay that's a mess all right so once you
take the top this is much easier than
what i did last night and it's making a
lot more noise which is cool that's uh
what this is you recommend for people to
do this in their house like with kids
around
uh maybe outdoors huh
[Applause]
there we go all right uh there good
enough
okay so then what another tool i use is
a drill for doing like nostrils and
things like that so
what does that do just cutting out
making holes
there you go you got that one
[Applause]
and by the way there's a kind of uh it's
exciting to do that it feels good yeah
yeah you're winning you're winning the
pumpkin is like no no and i'm like yeah
yeah yeah
the pumpkins like exactly well don't get
crazy that's sexy
all right let's go another toy use is
this thing what is that
what does that do i call it a pumpkin
gooper i made you one check yours out
oh my oh oh that's sweet look at my
pumpkin gooper right there it's
like his head you see that yeah it's got
a little and that goes in there and you
just
you whip it around like that give it a
try so this this is what takes the
longest time is scooping the goop
out of the empty pumpkin so you're
saying you put this
that's pretty good you have to hold hold
me while i do it
can't let the pumpkins win you can't let
the pumpkin switch this is america after
all
okay wanna do one more uh i want to do a
lot more
all right well let's grab that pumpkin
over there on the edge okay
this one here yeah we're gonna use a
chainsaw a chainsaw yeah
i've never used a chainsaw before oh
that'll go well in my life yeah
you can probably tell just by how i've
handled things so far that chainsaw is
right over here it's
that thing with a chain on it thanks pal
thanks for making me look even wussier
you push yeah there you go
what are we doing with this just take a
chunk off of this side
off this side like this
[Applause]
why did mine take so much longer than
yours i took the good one
i finished and you were reading a book
uh and then all right we made like
siamese twins out of that
[Applause]
all right you ready for this one just
had a lobotomy for the heavy art gallery
huh you ready for the big step oh my god
what is that tell me what that is well i
read that the world record for carving a
pumpkin is like 30 seconds or something
and i said i can do it in under a minute
if i make this so i made you one too
right there
can you demonstrate this and then i'll
try what is this thing called i call it
the pumpkin thumper
so you take a pumpkin like this yeah
hold on let me get out there i'm
slipping on
pumpkin intestine over here and then you
take this thing yeah
and you whack it like that
right here are you get that okay you
know how to split wood right
yeah i split wood all the time here we
go what are you talking about i split
with yesterday there you go
with the thing that has the chain on it
[Music]
okay
oh that was too hard yeah too much
muscle
[Applause]
okay that was too much there you go try
again
right here okay you got to get really
worked up into a rage when you do this i
think
son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
ready on three one
two three ah
[Applause]
oh that feels so good
okay i'm having a small series of heart
attacks right now
the book is extreme pumpkin too it's in
stores now you're a good man tom nardone
thank you very much